lamento de seleccionar a alguien que
pensó que esta plática va a ser de sexo
pero es de algo mejor es una historia de
amor
hace poco platicaba con un director de
una maquila muy importante en ciudad
juárez y me decía arturo sin lugar a
dudas tenemos el mejor plan de
compensaciones de cualquier empresa en
méxico y aún así nuestros trabajadores
se nos van
y esta es una queja cada vez más
recurrente de la poca lealtad que
muestran los trabajadores con sus
empresas de hecho se dice que las
generaciones millennials van a tardar
dos años en promedio en una empresa así
que los conceptos de lealtad orgullo
pertenencia y compromiso se están
quedando en el pasado
y como queremos resolver las cosas
agarrando los a punta de billetazos pero
nos estamos equivocando porque la
lealtad no se puede comprar
y lo que queremos es tener soldados que
se mueran por esta camisa pero lo que
tenemos son mercenarios que se venden al
mejor postor porque porque no hemos sido
capaces de crear verdaderas relaciones
laborales no las tenemos mentira no
tenemos relaciones laborales lo que
tenemos son transacciones laborales y
entonces por supuesto yo estoy a favor
de que tengamos sueldos dignos
pero el problema del dinero es que nunca
será suficiente
así que que que planteo bueno jack welch
xxi o de general electric dice tenemos
que encontrar la forma de capturar la
mente y el corazón de cada uno de
nuestros trabajadores y entonces yo lo
que planteo es qué
hagamos que nuestros colaboradores se
enamoren de la empresa porque además el
amor es la fuerza más poderosa de cambio
del universo así que yo propongo que
enamoramos a nuestra gente de tres cosas
de sus líderes de su trabajo y de su
empresa
primero enamorarnos de sus líderes y de
sus líderes
le hice un estudio de opinión en donde
le pregunté a 100 mexicanos así como el
programa le pregunté a 100 mexicanos qué
es lo que verdaderamente quieren de tu
trabajo
y los 100 nos contestaron lo mismo todos
nos dijeron dinero pero nos yo les dije
ok ya sé que quieres dinero pero si el
problema del dinero estuviera resuelto
que es lo que verdaderamente querrías de
tu vida de tu trabajo
y fue sorprendente la respuesta
contestaron un lugar donde me escuchen
donde me entiendan y donde me comprendan
entonces que tenemos que hacer tenemos
que provocar esa conexión emocional
entre nosotros y nuestros colaboradores
me tocó una vez que tuve la oportunidad
de dirigir una fuerza de ventas en una
empresa del sector financiero y a mí me
tocaba entrevistar a los candidatos
llega a uno con un currículum
impresionante y le digo me da pena
decirte esto pero tu currículum está
sobrepasado para el puesto
y me dice
necesito el trabajo
puedo empezar de abajo y te prometo que
te voy a dar resultados
esa pudo hacer una buena respuesta para
alguien pero no para mí
pero le pregunté y por qué
y me contestó
tengo una hija enferma
tiene leucemia y se está muriendo
y su tratamiento es muy costoso
yo le dije estás contratado
al poco tiempo se hace un concurso
nacional de ventas en donde el primer
premio era un viaje a cancún todo pagado
y este cuate lo gana
pero imagínense el ridículo que iba yo a
hacer si de repente llegó con él y le
digo papito te ganaste un viaje a cancún
todo pagado imagínate arena blanca mar
azul turquesa bikinis por todos lados
cuando esa persona se está debatiendo
entre la vida y la muerte de su hija
porque perdone pero no llegamos a la
oficina diciendo buenos días buenos días
mi hija se está muriendo
en cambio hablo con mi jefe y le digo
oye necesito que merece el premio en
efectivo no no se puede necesito que me
lo des en efectivo
total lo consigo llegó con esta persona
y le digo por tu buen desempeño te
ganaste un viaje a cancún
pero si tú así lo decides en este sobre
está el dinero
úsalo y salva a tu hija
tenemos que ser esos líderes que
impacten de forma positiva la vida de
nuestros colaboradores solo así se van a
enamorar de nosotros
segundo enamorarse de su trabajo cómo
podría yo enamorarme de mi trabajo bueno
si responde si a las siguientes dos
preguntas uno todos los días es lo que
más amas hacer y dos todos los días
haces lo que mejor sabes hacer
cuando tu todos los días hace es lo que
más amas a hacer estás ejerciendo tu
vocación y como decía para mí el más
grande atleta de toda la historia
michael jordan
tú sólo juega disfruta y diviértete y no
sé si por alguna extraña razón alguno de
ustedes se divierte en su trabajo alza
la mano quien se divierte en su trabajo
bueno son muy afortunados porque
como dice el comercial que te paguen por
hacer lo que te gusta no tiene precio
pero no basta también todos los días
tienes que hacer lo que mejor sabes
hacer y eso se llama ejercer su vocación
tu talento
y el talento es bíblico la palabra y de
hecho no te equivoques porque dios no lo
hace a todos nos dio un talento a todos
claro hay gente maravillosa que le dio
más de uno son los leo messi son la
celine dion son los al pacino pero como
siempre digo no te preocupes si estás
tienes uno
así que de alguna forma la pregunta es
cuál es tu talento porque además cuando
tú ejerces tu talento pasa algo
maravilloso te sientes pleno y
satisfecho porque lo que haces lo haces
bien pero lo mejor es que cuando tú
haces las cosas bien saben que viene a
continuación
ville marmara pachucha dolarucos
morlacos sor juana cacao pues
morning así que qué suerte si tú amas tu
trabajo pero el tercer punto es
enamorarse de su empresa
como yo podría amar a mi empresa muy
fácil a través de su cultura aunque a mí
me gusta llamarla sueño porque todas las
empresas del mundo todas nacieron con un
sueño
sin embargo somos muy malos para
comunicarnos
así que vayamos a la mejor empresa del
mundo para vender sueños que se llama
disney
y walter walt disney walter tuvo un
sueño
su familia tenía una granja de naranjas
en anaheim en california y él soñó y
dijo aquí voy a construir el lugar más
feliz sobre la tierra
y no sé si alguno de ustedes ha tenido
sueños locos pero ese era uno y walter
sabía perfectamente que todos los sueños
en la vida todos son posibles pero solo
no iba a poder hacerlo así que utilizó
su sueño para que se convirtiera en la
guía inspiracional para que muchos más
creyeran en él y así en julio de 1955
abre por primera vez y para siempre el
lugar más feliz sobre la tierra
y yo les prometo que si implementan el
amor en sus organizaciones van a ser
exitosos
tuve la oportunidad de tener una reunión
con don roberto servitje que contó con
su hermano don lorenzo forman hace
muchos años bimbo y don roberto nos
platicaba que junto con otras personas
es forma la empresa pero conforme
pasaron los años se fueron haciendo más
grandes y tuvieron que ir jubilándose
pero había una persona que no quería y
no quería y no quería hasta que
finalmente pues bueno lo jubilan pero
llega un año después a buscar a don
roberto y él lo recibe con mucho cariño
oye cómo estás pásale en qué puedo hacer
por ti y le dice esta persona don
roberto
ya me enteré
por cierto paréntesis mujeres no le
digan eso a los hombres porque me
insiste y nos ponen muy nerviosos le
dice ya me entere
y don roberto de que te enteraste
de que están estrenando uniformes quiero
que me regale uno y el sí claro pero
para que lo quieres
y él le contesta
quiero usarlo
el día de mi funeral
por eso bimbo es la panificadora más
grande del mundo porque han sido capaces
de enamorar a sus colaboradores de sus
líderes de su trabajo y de su empresa
pero concluyo con esto
yo quisiera invitarlos a que implementen
como una estrategia organizacional el
amor en sus empresas
pero que no se les olvide que también lo
hagan en su vida personal
porque hoy vivimos una era donde todos
estamos estresados angustiados
deprimidos temerosos hay una gran crisis
de relaciones divorcios separaciones
familias disfuncionales y parece que
estamos condenados a ser infelices
y tal vez la solución es más simple de
lo que pareciera
tal vez lo único que necesitamos es
llenar nuestra vida de amor para ser
felices
y darnos cuenta que tal vez necesitamos
muy poco para hacerlo
y tal vez lo único que necesitamos es
como escribieron los inolvidables john
lennon y paul mccartney en su canción
todo lo que necesitas es amor
gracias
[Aplausos]